all right Glenn let's let's get after it
what happened here what happened not a
great story man it's really like I I
wish it was as radical as when I broke
my collarbone snowboarding but it is so
isn't it was just it was really
embarrassing actually I was uh you know
I have a cat that's 20 years old
she's very very old and uh we've had her
I've had her pretty much her whole life
um and then we got a couple dogs a
couple years ago did you kick the dog I
didn't kick the dog did you kick the cat
I'm trying to make my neck hurt
[Laughter]
the toe neck you didn't get this well so
so yeah okay all right so so I think I
broke my toe yesterday but then I woke
up this morning and I and and my neck
was [ __ ] up so I was like oh my god oh
I didn't see that in the text all I saw
was were photos of your foot and I
couldn't get past it okay yeah yeah yeah
uh all right so I'll get to the neck
thing but uh
so and it may maybe maybe what happened
how I broke my toe is what triggered the
neck to begin with OR set set me up for
neck failure uh but uh long story short
we have to put up a gate right so our
house is divided in half the cat has one
half of that
and then all of you live on the other
side
you've awarded the cat half your home
the cats and dogs just they can't you
know
humans they can't live together they
can't they just can't live together and
and in some circumstances when cats and
dogs do live together uh peacefully is
that I I always imagine that's because
the dog was there either the dog and the
cat came at the same time or uh and the
cat was a kitten or the dogs were there
first that's what I've got comes in
today
okay what am I saying dogs cats getting
along just fine but dogs were there
first yeah cat came in but when the cat
came in was introduced in our house the
cat kicked the dog's ass like I mean oh
yeah yeah established dominance
absolutely and now it's it's stasis yeah
our cat my cat was like I'm from the
streets you know like back and the dogs
were like I'm from somewhere fancy I
don't know I don't know
created I'm from their wombs yeah yeah
my cat is 20 so she can't do that no
yeah you have the ability to do that and
my my dogs just look at her and they're
just like oh delicious uh or I just want
to play with that yeah I want a thing or
whatever you know riled up anyway so we
got to keep them separated
um and uh and so we have the dog gate
and the dog Gate's not that hard to step
over you know but it's a little awkward
and sometimes you snag your toe on it
right or whatever like you just kind of
kick it a little bit you're like it's
annoying and then you just keep moving
uh I'm gonna guess that that enrages you
when it happens
yeah I know I know the feeling I've
tripped over that thing a couple times
and your first reaction is like why the
[ __ ] you're like
um I hate this [ __ ] gate yeah yeah
yeah yeah in this particular instance
though I really caught the almost the
whole foot were you moving at a good
clip I was carrying a bunch of stuff I
had a bunch of stuff flying everywhere
in a humorous way
Yes actually it did oh well that's good
I was caring I had a I had a metal like
a you know a stainless steel water
bottle and something else so you got a
good clang when he dropped it yeah yeah
so it was even better than Jill had a
suitcase like right near where I was
falling also that was upright so I trip
over the gate I fall I'm basically doing
a face plant right
the water bottle goes flying out of my
hands it it clangs super loud onto the
ground the only thing that saves me is
the suitcase I grabbed the suitcase so
instead of having to land on the hard
ground I I like you know grab the
suitcase and just like landed on the
suitcase with my hands you know what I
mean and I was like you know Jill comes
firing out of the out of the office
she's on a phone call and she's like
something happened something happened
and then she comes firing out of the
office and she's like she's like are you
okay and I was like I was like yeah I
just I tripped over the gate I was like
I I
hate that [ __ ] gate I think I you
know cursed at the gate a little bit but
I was like no but I'm I think I'm okay
I'm all right I'm fine and I was with my
buddy uh Rich up hell because we were
doing a writing session and uh and rich
is just laughing at me
um and I was like okay no I think I
think I'm fine I hate that [ __ ] gate
we gotta get Mike all right whatever and
then so rich and I go downstairs to the
to to my office to to work
and all of a sudden like I just start
I'm like oh there's something wrong with
that toe and then I looked at it and
there was like a little like it looked
like it was kind of jutting out on the
side a little bit like like maybe I
I don't know like maybe I broke it broke
it yeah yeah so I think I broke the toe
I don't know how the toe got broken by
the way I didn't land on the toe I
didn't
that's not even what got snagged on the
game barefoot no I was wearing like
slides
did they go flying as well oh do you
have cameras no no I do like security
cameras and [ __ ] right outside
nah I don't have them inside we drew the
line at having security cameras inside
we were like that's just creepy yeah
um I don't think the shoes went flying I
think I managed to keep the the slides
on
uh and maybe that's what broke my toe I
don't know but it's uh and then I woke
up this morning it was yeah I sent you
guys the picture maybe we should put it
on the podcast that's pretty gross yeah
it's pretty we've been saying we want to
get more feet we've got to get more feet
on the spot yeah yeah we just
established that people are obsessed
with uh people's feet so yeah why not
and then I woke up this morning totally
unrelated possibly and just and I was
like like it was like one of those
things where you know you're 46 years
old and uh my alarm goes off and you
know I I go to get up out of bed and I
was like oh
ah I was like oh [ __ ] now I'm walking
around my house like trying to get ready
to come here this morning and I'm like I
can't I'm actually I walk fine but it
it's slowing me down a little bit
because like I make whatever it's
talking to me the whole time let's just
move on to something else
[Music]
I drank a lot last night really yeah
again oh cause you went out I went out
but I didn't Emmy partner yes Caitlyn
wanted to go Caitlyn was nominated for
neme and I and we did not go to the
Emmys but we went to the she wanted to
go to the After parties to be clear she
was not nominated for It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia because that doesn't
happen she was nominated for hacks yes
um and so we went to the after party but
it didn't start until 9 or 9 30. now I'm
I'm usually in bed at 9 30. 10 o'clock
I'm in I'm definitely late start to
party that's yeah at this point in life
you gotta edit the school night right so
you know you're gonna we both had to get
up we both had to get up nice and early
without room you didn't get the get the
nanny or babysitter to no spend the
night what time did you guys leave that
Sunday night party oh late late 12 30.
oh actually I have an amazing story
about that but I want I'll I'll tell
that later go ahead I was just
commiserating with how how I was feeling
I'm actually feeling okay but so you
you're right you're a little hungover I
drank an entire Manhattan before I left
the house because sure because why not
because yeah Manhattan time it was past
Manhattan time
yeah what's going on now usually you
drink in Manhattan go to sleep but now
I'm drinking the Manhattan I'm going out
this man's unable to have to like go
through a night without having a
Manhattan so what time do you usually
have your men have I usually have it
around seven o'clock it's about like 6
40. 6 45 my body's like okay you know
where is it seven it's like yeah now
it's time 7 15. it's best yeah you need
you're you're you're starting to with
food after no I eat dinner I eat dinner
first so it's honest it's not a full
stomach but it's a good three shots of
whiskey oh I've seen your Manhattan yeah
yeah three three something about it's I
don't actually measure it now when you
say three shots we talk in one and a
half ounce shots are we talking
like oh yeah I fill it up as we've
discussed I fill it up to the brim but
it's bigger than those glasses there
it's it's it's three shots to one so
it's three shots of um of bourbon and
one shot of vermouth and I can handle
that
um so I'm feeling pretty good when I go
to the party but then I had you had
florals old fashions
a Monday morning I woke up just been
like what was I thinking man it's a
school day I gotta get I gotta get the
kid to school I'm like I'm I can't I
can't drive a car so for the listener
what we're talking about is there's a
there's a big preemie party that happens
uh the Sunday night before the Emmys and
we uh went to this uh went to this party
and you know you see a bunch of friends
that you haven't seen in a really long
time and you get after it yeah which we
don't do very often these days no this
this year the party was very loud there
were some live Snoop Dogg performed that
was very cool 50 Cent performed that was
really cool and it sounded great but it
was a little harder to socialize yeah
and you can hear it in my voice that's
not the alcohol that's me screaming over
the that's the concert so that's two
nights in a row that that we went out
yeah so we were screaming over the music
you know uh that night and then you know
I broke my toe and screamed about that's
more and ruined my voice even more which
is why my voice is messed up and then
something else happened I screamed about
too but we won't get into that but what
was your great story at the party you
said you had an amazing okay well I'm
building it up too much but uh this this
is amazing so so
um
you know FX was kind enough to provide
us with a with a car okay what time did
you leave the party at that night yeah
uh 11 30 something okay what time did
you leave yeah like midnight okay okay
so the party was supposed to go to
midnight right so my car was booked
apparently to midnight
so we left at 12 30. my car was [ __ ]
gone and I'm texting the guy and he's
like he was like he was like no you were
supposed I was supposed to drop you off
at midnight and I was like buddy I don't
have a curfew what the [ __ ] are you
talking about wait a second yeah uh same
thing for me so we left now I'm piecing
it together but we left at like 11 50
and the guy said good I'm glad you're
leaving because you have the car to
midnight and he was very he was really
scary like sized man yeah and he was a
very sweet guy and he kind of like was
he liked me and Mary Elizabeth so he
would like was staying a little bit
later for us but yeah they they were
like
yeah there's like a pumpkin effect you
know at midnight this thing's gone and
yeah you couldn't believe it we're
walking out of this party you know it's
a it's it's a very fancy Emmy party
everybody's dressed up in cocktail
everybody's got like you know let's talk
about champagne problems
this reminds me of the last episode when
we one of the tweets was something about
how like these tired olds
this is this is this is what you get
guys you know like there's something you
don't have to watch you but we're
irritated about our fancy things listen
Mike Mike we're hungover we know you're
on the way to work right now and you're
listening to this and you're and you're
about to get up on a roof yeah and I get
that I get that cleanse limousine left
my ass the party that he was at and
couldn't take Tim back to his house
discount card it's so big he can give
half of it
is so big he gets he gives half a bit to
a cat to a dog yep and then I go by the
way I don't know if you also caught this
but Jill came out of her office because
she was concerned about me and then I
went down to my house
basement it ready for California because
that's an earthquake nightmare that
became that can become a tomb no no
there's there's we've got Escape hatches
don't worry about it uh he's had Escape
patches put into his domicile is he a
man with tunnels
that's code you gotta have you gotta
have an Escape Route but it's
embarrassing you know it's all these
fancy people here you know you're you're
walking out of the party you see a lot
of your friends they're all walking on
everybody's getting into their cars I
see Paul Walter Hauser there again and
I'm like and and Jill was like hey maybe
we can jump in with Paul and I was like
that's just that's embarrassing it's
like I can't do that man so we called an
Uber and it were black
yeah an Uber SUV yeah and did that take
you home yeah and it got there in one
minute and and it took us to the hotel
oh great because oh yes we were smart
enough to get a hotel room that night
because we didn't want to have to wake
up and take the kids to school so we was
just like the Four Seasons or something
in that that's right now so somewhere in
Beverly Hills yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the weird
thing about those After parties though
man lots of upset people oh really oh
yeah oh you can feel it there's
something there's a palpable
disappointment because look here's
here's the the truth of it there is not
that we would really know but in talking
to many friends who are nominated year
after year after year who don't win we
act so we're never invited to the party
we're never even nominated which we're
not even asked to like present an award
which which pisses us off to a certain
extent but it frees us up that night as
opposed to people that get dressed up
starting at two o'clock in the afternoon
because it's West Coast time it's 100
trees they go there they sit there and
the first second third Award of the
night is presented they don't get it and
they got to sit there for three hours
poor people oh listen all you guys that
are on your way to work you know you
don't know
brought to a fancy party and and given a
free beautiful dress for talks and it's
yeah it's air-conditioned in there but
it's too cold yeah and it's and it
toxins your tux is a little tight
because I want to fit right because
you've been stress eating because you
think you're going to win some big award
and have to give her you're starving
because you've been starving yourself to
fit into your tuxedo or your dress yeah
yeah and and so you're suffering in that
regard and then there you gotta sit
there and listen to some uh funny
stand-up comedian you know present all
these Awards and uh boy I tell you it's
it's just like it's just like Plumbing
you know what I mean I'll say I watched
a little bit of it because um because
Caitlyn was on a show that was nominated
and uh Keenan was the host he's really
okay
he was really funny I thought he was
really really yeah and a great guy man
how unbelievably self-congratulatory is
the entire bro I mean that's what the
whole thing is anyway but man it is like
an they won't even have editors on the
show they got arbitrary awards for
Imaginary achievements sure I mean it's
absolutely I mean but really like it's
like it's true you can't there's no way
to qualify it yeah you know like so if
you win a green jacket for the Masters
you won that [ __ ] yeah yeah you
showed up for four days and you got the
ball in the hole and less shots than
anybody else and there's no disputing it
yeah and like with any kind of acting
award and you're like I don't know like
how can you win like best comedy actor
and then like leave a party and bump
into like Danny McBride you know I mean
I'd be like oh this guy's not even like
on the radar yeah yeah yeah and he
doesn't get he didn't get he's one of
the funniest people
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh there's
a it's not Madness a common
misconception amongst uh Hollywood
people that or maybe the general public
that the awards were created just as yes
self-congratulation but also as like a
marketing Ploy just to get people to pay
attention to the so I did a little
research into this because I was like
wait what why why was this started it
seems like a interesting and fascinating
you're researching what what started the
Emmy yeah what started like the Oscars
the Emmys and it was like way more
nefarious than that it was that the
studio heads who were used to having
people under contract for years and
years notice that the the artists were
starting to speak to one another and
unionize and create companies together
what they realized was we can't have
that oh they needed to create we need to
create competition amongst these people
and let them throw them a bone have them
all fight amongst each other as to who's
the who's the funniest who's the best
who's the who's who's the most deserving
of our attention and love and like
children they will destroy each other
amazing that's brilliant it's fun if you
win it is fun yeah Megan is the only uh
no wait a minute oh yeah oh wait yeah
wait wait wait wait you want an Emmy I
did win an Emmy when I was writing for
Modern Family did I know this and I'm
forgetting I I don't know I don't
mention it every episode but
it's it's surprising that it's not sort
of I know yeah you should maybe bring it
in and put it on your desk for a little
bit Yeah Yeah speaking of Modern Family
uh
I met I said hello to Jesse Tyler
Ferguson who I never met well I'm pretty
sure had absolutely no idea no yes no he
does he does I've had him over for
dinner at my house yeah yeah yeah he
knows he knows the show he just didn't
recognize me maybe you just don't you
don't pop off the show I think
no I think I look so good at the event I
look so good
this is like this is obviously like some
kind of action superhero you did look at
all of our wives look really good I
looked it back at some of those photos
and Mary Elizabeth looks amazing
Caitlyn and then I look at us I'm like
yeah I'm just like middle-aged guys yes
he looks good yeah look good I thought I
thought we did I don't know I don't know
I I don't like the uh I don't like the
picture that that came out of that FX
Vanity Fair party of me I don't know
it's like we took we took like you know
they did they took like 30 pictures of
me and the one they chose this I'm like
this I'm like
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know one shoulders up I look I look
like uh I don't know how to you know I
look like I can't sit up because there's
no Direction
yeah get into like more like ghoul
characters more ghouls
you gotta keep evolving you know you
gotta change yeah that's true I would
love to play more Ghouls and hunchbacks
foreign
have you guys ever taken like an online
quiz that just totally nailed you as a
person oh yeah yeah are we talking like
those uh BuzzFeed uh quizzes like which
Harry Potter character are you oh yeah
yeah no I was not I was not talking
about that but is that your thing yeah
which is it though which one which
character your Draco Malfoy oh he's
Draco yeah Draco that's pretty cool he
was yeah he had the slick back hair
that's the guy with the the blonde uh no
actually what I'm talking about is an
online uh sleep quiz from Helix sleep
and let me tell you this is a this is a
useful tool I took the Helix sleep quiz
did you take the quiz yeah what I
discovered was that I I I I'm most at
rest on a medium firm mattress which
steered me towards several models and
away from several others you know I went
I went with helix's sister brand Birch
organic which that that's the one that I
personally love take the word of their
10-year warranty and 100 night risk-free
sleep trial if you don't love it they'll
even come to pick it up for you but you
will love it right now Helix is offering
up to 200. is off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at Helix sleep.com slash sunny
[Music]
all right gang guess who we're sponsored
by today
you guessed it that's right it's a
nutritionally balanced plant-based Meal
made in less than a
you didn't guess it listen less than a
minute you know sometimes when we're on
the set of sunny our days are so packed
it's hard to even stop for 30 minutes to
eat lunch thank God for huel Glenn I
think you love you will be cause you get
to shake it up you know what I mean you
don't waste time cooking and cutting and
worst of all chewing that's right I
drink my food okay all I do is add two
scoops of heel to water shake and ingest
okay Precious seconds minutes even back
into my day well you also must love that
each meal contains 400 calories 40 grams
of expertly sourced premium plant
protein all 26 essential vitamins and
minerals and a scientifically calibrated
mix of carbs good fats and fibers come
on and join the club go to huel.com
Sunny to get a free t-shirt and a free
Shaker with your first order that's
pretty cool
rob you had an experience with the
French recently where you uh what was it
you went to the country what I'd like to
do is I'd like to have some French
people call in because I want to have
some conversations now again you can't
I'm not going to demonize an entire
country when you say French people I
think we need to clarify we're talking
about people who are from France like
who lived in France like grew up in
France like possibly most of their lives
yes they should have an accident one of
my best friends in New York City and my
roommate was French he was wonderful his
family was wonderful all like and he
would have his friends come in from
France and they were fantastic people
yeah okay so obviously it's not an
entire nation but there is a stereotype
about the French that I find to be very
often true I will say though I I was in
Switzerland right one side is uh speaks
German and then the other side that
borders France uh the primary language
is French and this was French
lovely oh well like the French Canadians
we're talking about France France you're
talking about the France France the
France French
yeah it's a whole thing that's a whole
thing I had an almost and Caitlyn will
corroborate this entire thing because
she was right there and witnessed the
whole thing okay it was almost a
physical altercation with a French woman
and I did nothing she was a little kind
of hot
she was not attractive oh she was
bumping into me even better it was it
was bizarre all right set it up take me
there take me there I couldn't take my
cigarette I'm in France for a layover
we're on our way to Wales you're doing a
little layup in France just a little
layoffs doing layups in France and we go
into this one particular section where
they where they where they hold you so
you're in the airport I'm in the airport
Everyone's an [ __ ] in the airport
sure there is definitely a a higher
level of anxiety at an at an airport but
I think you
account for that especially if you work
at the airport as did this woman oh yes
dude Court yeah that's like food court
area and the the first thing we hear
is a woman within a British accent and
she's saying all I want is a glass of
water can you just please bring me a
glass of water and this woman is saying
in a French accent which I will not try
to replicate ma'am please will you just
go sit down if you'd like to fill out a
report you can fill out a report and
she's saying I don't want to report I
just want a glass of water there is no
water
now my first reaction was Karen this is
a Karen who needs to talk to the manager
right and that's what she kept saying
like who's your boss where is the
manager and I was like oh that's like
Karen RIT large yeah so Caitlin and I
kind of roll our eyes we go sit down we
feel so bad for the employees that they
have to deal with this woman
so we then notice that the woman doesn't
get her glass of water but she goes over
and she's got a baby and the baby I mean
an infant right and and the infant is is
being rocked by her husband her husband
is like trying to calm her down
and we're like what is going on here but
then we look around and there's there's
no nothing like this is a cafeteria so
the whole point of it is to eat and
drink
and all of the water pitchers are
completely empty and all and so we're
like oh so this woman like wanted wanted
some water which she paid for because
you like pay a fee and then you eat it's
like a buffet style right yeah so we're
like okay so I don't know who's in the
wrong who's in the right whatever
a few but the scales of Justice
I've been watching this and we're like
okay
you're right I'm hearing who's in the
room right
absolutely now my kids constantly
monitoring this my kids are sitting
there right my kids are sitting there
and Caitlyn is sitting there and I'm
sitting there and I'm actually I feel
pretty good I have a full night's sleep
on the way over there so I'm feeling I'm
feeling great maybe you've got a bottle
of smart water in your backpack yeah I
didn't have anybody the water didn't
need any water you were already watching
now I'm watching I'm watching what's
happening because I'm watching her go
back to her husband and I'm expecting
the husband to explode or whatever but
no he's just like it's okay well he's
British yes and then she picks up the
baby and she's walking around with the
baby and I realized I'm thinking well
this woman seems kind of actually pretty
sweet and all she wanted was a glass of
water and then Caitlyn goes over to get
a glass of water and there's no water
and she's like wow I just want to get a
glass a glass water I was like oh this
is
this is gonna be amazing yeah and then
she goes you know what I just wanna I'm
just gonna get some caught some coffee
said okay so she goes and fills up some
coffee but she can't find any milk and
we see the milk and the cream is also
empty now again this is not just like a
Lobby of like a random like a subway
station this is actually there for this
very purpose right we pay a fee you eat
the goddamn food
but I'm like and and then I said you
want me to get you some milk and then
Caitlyn actually said yeah but I don't
want you to get into a whole thing with
the uh basically you're like when do you
want me to step in yeah do you want to
get involved yes I will be I will be
perfectly perfectly nice and sweet and I
will just ask where the at first where
the milk is and so I I now this same
woman is over there and she's like
cleaning this area right where the milk
and the coffee the woman that the other
woman was asking for water earlier yes
and the woman was very clearly speaking
in English to to this woman yeah so I
walk over to the woman and I and I
recognize I'm not in my own country and
that people speak French I don't speak
French but it's an airport I just
watched her speak English so but I'll be
respectful and I'll just say excuse me
and I'll point to to the thing and I'll
say do you have any more of this
and I say hi excuse me and she looks up
at she and she rolls her eyes
immediately and I said oh and now I'm
already like oh yeah yeah
so that Rob Justice
did you ask her if there was a phone
booth somewhere where you could
and I said I'm so sorry
um
do you have any more milk and I pointed
to it I said just the milk is empty
and she goes uh she said something in
French and I said I'm so sorry I I don't
I've apologized four times already yeah
I'm so sorry I don't I don't speak
French but I'm just looking for this for
milk and she goes over there
she didn't even say that she said it in
French she like pointed and says like go
go away go over there go over there and
I was like oh sorry is it over there and
she just looks at me and she goes
and I said oh okay great so I go over to
the other station no milk nothing just
nothing around there
and there's nobody else there so then
there was I I walk like around to a
different area and there was a woman
there and she was dressed in the Garb of
people who work at at the cafeteria and
I say
sorry I'm looking for milk for coffee
and she just dead pan stares at me and
says
I don't speak and I heard her say
English like I don't how do you say I
don't speak English in French
[Music]
and I was and I literally said the same
thing
sorry I know I don't I don't speak
French I just want milk and she just
goes go away and I was like holy [ __ ]
she said go go away
I [ __ ] [ __ ] you not go away and I was
like oh I guess you speak English and
then she goes seal excuse me and she
walks away and I'm like what the [ __ ]
this is uh I feel like this isn't a
movie this is there's no way this is
outrageous can I ask how busy this
cafeteria is is it like packed with
people no no empties okay empty now I
walk over to the woman with the baby and
I say hi and she's like hi I'm like did
you get your glass of water yet and she
was like no they just like refused to
bring me water and I'm like okay this is
[ __ ] nuts so I go back to the woman
who was cleaning up it again and I said
we paid money to be here I want a glass
of water and I want milk
right and she says the same thing like I
don't I don't speak English and then she
bumps into me and I don't move I just
stand there like she's trying to get
past me yeah and she's like she looks
right at me and I'm like go get security
go get security and she goes something
in French something in French something
in French
and I was like I'm not gonna move until
you bring me a glass of water and milk
now Caitlyn is like
that's exactly how I feel I'm like am I
an ugly American right now right so I'm
going through the checklist and I'm like
I have apologized ten thousand times
yeah I recognize that I don't speak
French I'm not I'm not suggesting that
you should know how to speak English but
you've already demonstrated that you do
yes you work in an airport we paid a fee
to be here and you have a chip on your
shoulder about Americans and clearly the
British as well to the point where you
want to pick a fight with us for some
reason and I'm just not having it so I
just don't move and then she goes around
me and my kids are just like Dad Dad Dad
stop and I'm like [ __ ]
oh my God people are walking in
and now like everybody's invested
because when we first walked in we were
so embarrassed for this British woman
yeah who was like making a Ruckus and
now everybody is looking at me and this
woman because now she's walked away and
she's going to talk to
her co-worker another co-worker and
they're like yelling at me in French and
I'm yelling back and back in English
people are all like watching us and I'm
like oh now I'm the the app yeah you're
the American [ __ ] yeah now I'm the
Karen yeah you're the Kevin and So So
eventually some nobody brings us water
nobody brings us milk but they they
restock it and when I walk back over
there
um i s I said something I just didn't
even say anything to her I just looked
at her and she looked at me and I said
what do you want to say and then she
said uh she said
um I'm I'm gonna go get security and I
said oh you speak English now and she
goes
yes and she turns around and walks away
and I was like what the [ __ ] this is
insane I can't wait to talk to security
so I get the water I get the milk which
they've just restocked I come back
nobody comes back of course we then we
then wind up sitting next to the woman
with the baby on the plane she couldn't
have been sweeter could have been nicer
was traveling back from London all she
wanted was a glass of water now again
this could be an isolated incident it
could have been just one person
or if it's it there's a system it's it's
there's a systemic issue
let's find out with I think you're right
I think we should have some French
people call in talk about their
experiences with Americans and you know
because maybe
something happened along the lines where
well of course now this these people
were doing it to this uh this this
British woman as well but where you know
they're
they've got a chip on their shoulders
specifically about Americans because
they find them to be so crass and rude
and clearly they do and then I'm my
behavior is just reinforcing that but
from a but she she both both of the
people recognize what the situation was
they they know that they were the
aggressors they they absolutely know
that they brought it yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
it's not if you're working as an
employee and your job is you know
serving people water and someone asks
you for a glass of water give them a
[ __ ] glass of water yeah there's no
excuse for that yeah I think it was like
are you so entitled that you believe you
deserve a glass of water and milk and
the answer is yeah man well if I paid
for it and this is a place of business
and I'm then yeah then I am actually
entitled to it I was at the airport once
in in Paris from Mary Elizabeth and I
don't know if you remember like where
the baggage comes out it's like a gla
it's glass so instead of like LAX where
you just don't know where these bags are
coming from you can see the employees
you can see through the glass right and
they went on break
they went on break for an hour and you
could just see them sitting on the bags
smoking cigarettes
like yeah just well you I mean half a
cigarette but put the bag on the thing
and have it come through sit
been well well I said if you guys
couldn't smoke and work at the same time
the entire country would shut down
I know you can do it yeah you're still
smoking yeah so I guess what I'd like to
know is I'd like to speak with some
French people and I would just want to
ask them what their experience is and is
it and I'm willing to accept this that
that there is just a cultural difference
that like being an [ __ ] is is okay
and again there are lots of American
[ __ ] oh yeah I mean go to yeah any
airport in a major city in America and
like the people there are exhausted and
overworked and grumpy and and you know
Jill and I Jill and I uh 12 years ago we
did a we spent three months traveling
around Europe to many different
countries
and France definitely stood out as like
yeah yeah as being just the people just
were rude they were more rude per per
square person you know what I mean not
everybody was rude certainly not
everybody you know what I mean but more
people were rude towards it seems more
commonly unacceptable as a culture yeah
to be to be rude to like 15 different
countries yeah and then there was no it
was no comparison no comparison yeah
where does that start that stereotype
comes from something in somewhere so I I
would like to I would like to really dig
into this I would like to have the
discussion with some I think yeah I'd
also like to get Caitlyn's uh side of
what she saw happening because we we
then discussed it and then I you know
anytime again like an event like that
happens with the kids I sit I I have to
ask them like we have to process it
because like watching your dad scream at
somebody else and back and forth at an
airport is like very traumatizing so we
talk about it but like I also don't
I also want to make sure that they that
you know you never want to take things
to to a certain level but again I I
don't I don't think we should be treated
a certain way and if someone's treating
you a certain way I can't imagine your
dad screaming
sorry when I say screaming that's not I
know actually raising your voice yes in
in Anger not screaming but like standing
your ground with a loud voice yes well
well because it was it was directed back
at me so they were trying to like
humiliate me and I was like I was just
return returning it and I was most
likely escalating it but again yeah I I
always had that gear
yes yeah right I I picture you always
having that you get that from your mom
where does that come from
I don't know were you a hall monitor at
school
no my confrontation
I'm the same way I I can't I can't I
can't handle things like that I don't
handle things like that well I probably
would have done something very similar
yeah I I don't know I mean and if I back
off at this point it's so that I don't
traumatize my kids or or scare them or
embarrass Jill you know what I mean yeah
uh it but like if I'm by myself oh
[ __ ] forget about it yeah [ __ ]
forget about it I I I can't I can't I'm
the same way I can't stand that [ __ ] it
just feels like there are certain people
who walk around the world and they just
treat people whatever way that they want
and I can't I don't know yeah I'm like
I'm not the one you're not gonna treat
me like that and I don't think I'm gonna
teach you any lessons you're probably
not going to change but the lesson I am
teaching you right now is get the [ __ ]
away from me yeah your [ __ ] ain't gonna
work on me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and and yes of course upon
reflection you feel
bad and then I try to process it and say
did I handle that in the best of ways
like so the the um the in and out thing
right so like I came in the next day and
we discussed it and we got I was really
introspective about that and trying to
figure out try to figure out the next
time that something like that happens I
know that there's a better way to handle
that and I have to like work through it
and in this circumstance I don't know
that there really was a better way to
handle that well
you injured anyone you just but it could
be your opinions culture Clash right and
and that is like look and there's no
denying the fact that Americans on the
whole on the whole I think are more
entitled
uh we live in a more entitled culture
than most other cultures we're like I am
entitled to this yes you know what I
mean and sometimes sometimes that
entitlement is right you know what I
mean in in this case I would say that it
was right because you paid for service
the service was not rendered and so you
said Hey listen I paid for a thing I
expect to get the thing the thing is is
like culturally I think there are a lot
of people who are so used to not getting
what they want not getting what they
need not getting what's certainly not
getting what they desire and and and and
and they're just they just realize that
it's futile to even you know you realize
you're like you learn to go through life
not getting the things that you've that
that we feel like we're entitled to
because we have been so fortunate in
this country to to have so many
opportunities so many things you know uh
to live in a world where maybe for the
most part the scales of Justice are more
balanced than in other places uh but now
it's at a point where you know
everyone's like okay and the American
dream where is it yeah I should I would
have it now you know what I mean
my barometer for those kinds of things
is pretty good meaning like if I just
walked around the French airport and was
like bring me water you know and I
where's my milk to the to the random you
know like baggage handler yeah um
because I deserve milk
yes that would make me an entitled
American [ __ ] yes but if someone's
gonna charge me you know thirty dollars
ahead to come in and eat at your Buffet
then yes I believe I'm in that the third
that the transaction entitles me to a
glass yes and by the way I 100 agree I
just think I just think maybe I'm just
I'm I'm participating where
it becomes a chicken it becomes a
chicken or the egg thing too right
because then those people have dealt
with the worst versions of the Karens or
the Rob justices over the last you know
30 years to your point Charlie and now
they just assume everybody's like that
and that and they act accordingly so
when you had a chance to talk you
haven't had a chance to talk to Caitlin
about this and and her perspective or
you just want her to no I'd love for her
to weigh in because it's always good to
hear
a third party perspective of like
because you're in the middle of the
event and then you have other people can
we call her watch I know is she do you
think she's around like you can send her
Zoom link you guys could zoom let me
just call Caitlyn and see if she'll just
because it might be fun
laughs
and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp betterhelp is an online
therapy service that can help you find
solutions to a variety of life's
problems Injustice in just so many
injustices in the world okay now here
comes Rob Justice Rob Justice in the
house okay Rob Justice is hell bent
on Justice and is willing to die for it
but with convenient affordable and
entirely online therapy like better help
Rob Justice can see himself grow into
raw acceptance which doesn't sound
nearly as angry no no he's not he's
actually he's actually quite Zen so if
you're thinking of trying therapy but
you don't know where to start consider
solving that problem by starting with
better help when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can help with
that right so so visit betterhelp.com
sunny today and get 10 off your first
month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash sunny
today we are brought to you by
ZipRecruiter zip recruiter makes it
super easy to find the right people for
the job whatever job it is you're trying
to fill do you guys have any jobs jobs
are you asking for a job I'm poking
around for a job a little bit now I
could use a relief Nanny you know
someone to step in when my nanny gets
sick you know you just have to recognize
that she's number one and you're number
two you okay now can you handle that
pass I'm not going to Nanny uh your
children or raise your children
um not because I I not qualified because
I just don't want to I only want you to
do it if you want to do I don't want to
do it let me tell you let me tell you
who does one dude the actual ideal
candidate is out there and and zip
recruiter is a powerful technology that
finds awesome people who have the skills
and experience to match your job listing
four out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day look just go to
ziprecruiter.com put in slash sunny and
then find the employees you're looking
for ziprecruiter.com sunny
[Music]
oh hello
hi hi Caitlyn hi okay what do you want
from me so I I wanted to get a um
your point of view of what happened in
the French airport lounge cafeteria
section that we
went to God Rob told us the whole story
but be honest be honest what's your take
on it all what from your perspective was
it like when Rob Justice got stepped
into the picture and got himself
involved you know put on his cape put on
his mask and you know ripped his ripped
his shirt open and became Rob Justice
what was that like be honest don't do a
bit tell them exactly what happened how
did you feel how did you feel how did
you feel how did I feel well it
escalated very quickly but it I was I
was very happy that he was trying to
find me some cream because I found
coffee now I can't find water and I got
coffee and I can't find cream and I'm
just tired and I we all were tired and I
said I can't find cream for the coffee
and he was like okay let me look and he
walked up and he asked this woman
um
where the cream was for the coffee did
and I think she kind of ignored you or
something I'm I'm not really paying
attention I just know that very quickly
he turned
very upset with this person and he was
like uh here's the coffee I don't see
any cream and then she was like trying
to push past him and he was like are you
are you trying you want to get by me
just go by me don't touch me just go buy
me he's assaulting me she's assaulting
me this French woman I was assaulted at
an airport okay I just it looked like
she was trying to get away from you and
walk by you but you needed your cream
but the cream was for me so I'm on board
but it was she was she was physically
bumping into me trying to like it was
bizarre he was walking yes towards you
and trying to get around you and then
yeah you threw you were bouncing off
this out and your arms up and you're
like you want to go by me go buy me now
how are you feeling when you see him
start to get into the red where are you
emotional yeah are you like ah [ __ ] or
are you like yeah are you like good I'm
glad he's speaking up or are you like oh
Rob come on just forget it I don't
really need the cream yeah uh both
because this woman was being an an
[ __ ] she was really like
aggressively being unhelpful so I got
that he was upset but also my kids are
right there and I just kind of would
rather you know maybe I just drink the
coffee black I don't think I needed to
turn it to a whole thing but I do
understand why he was upset but see
that's but wherein lies the problem
right we paid for the goddamn coffee
paid for the food you're not and you're
and she shouldn't have to drink like
should you have to drink Black Coffee in
real life is that um like a a a huge
sacrifice you have to of course not who
gives a [ __ ] really but what you paid
the Goddamn money where's my [ __ ]
cream but when does standing up for
yourself when does it create more
problems for yourself absolutely yeah
when does it tip over into like oh I've
upset my children and now it's like what
do you think do you think Rob is out of
line or do you think that that he like
if the kids weren't there I would have
done the exact same thing I just
instantly turned into like Mama Bear and
wanted him to stop so that they weren't
like seeing their dad get to fight over
cream because they weren't understanding
that she was being an [ __ ] and she
was the woman who wasn't giving this
woman the water earlier I recognized her
from the previous incident so I if they
weren't there I would have done the
exact same thing well so to be honest
that's where it becomes a question
though right because if if Rob's
behavior is Justified then he's actually
teaching his kids the right thing that's
how I feel in that circumstance but if
it's not if he shouldn't be acting that
way then then then that's it's okay to
stand up for yourself if depending on
what you're you know my thing is that
the kids didn't see all the things
leading up to it they just saw Rob
yelling at this foreign
but then she revealed herself to speak
English correct that's true now they
didn't see that either again as as an
adult I saw the whole thing and I
understand the whole thing and I would
have been on board I just I'm more
willing to drop it when our kids are not
seeing any of that they're just seeing
their dad go to right well that's
because
Injustice well I was going to say that
Caitlyn could have been doing a
play-by-play with the kids as they're
watching she could have been the you
know the and you could have been saying
like you know this no this is now had I
had cream for my coffee and was
comfortable sitting back and sipping
while enjoying this scene play out I
probably would have been able to do that
but I was uncomfortable Glenn because my
coffee was black and I was tired and my
husband was fighting with a strange
woman uh yeah but did you eventually get
your cream
you would have gotten the cream without
the raised temper like if you just kind
of kept insisting on just uh well well
that's wherein lies the issue because
probably like there's a version of the
of this where I get it with I get the
cream but what happened was it started
with me wanting cream and then it
transitioned to me wanting cream and
Justice yeah yeah the the sweet cream of
justice is the sweetest cream of all
and yeah like doesn't that doesn't that
cream taste so sweet yeah yeah it's so
much better it is no justice is curdled
milk
and that really is that really is the
takeaway in what we talked to our kids
about afterwards okay so you just spoke
to them about the cream of justice and
you explained yeah maybe Rob Justice's
sidekick should just be a woman that
explains all of his behavior to any
children that are around so they have
the proper contacts
it's just a constant state of processing
with children Dad this is my dad's
behaving this way that's sweet that's me
I did I did give them a full a full
recap afterwards so that they would
understand because they were the little
one was just like his mouth was open and
his eyes were wide he was just like
shocked and confused so I backed up to
be fair by this point he should not be
shocked and confused by my behavior
I still like to hide it from them you're
really really trying to get them used to
it but Yep they're getting there well
it's they see it can't hide you can't
hide from your kids they see you they
see they know they know they know
I definitely know what's wrong and
when Rob's around that's for sure he'll
make sure that well we we also are gonna
we're gonna do a little call-in show
where we're gonna have people from
France specifically France French people
in English in English please oh yeah
yeah yeah we will force them to speak
English yeah uh and we're gonna get
their take on it but what it I mean is
your take on have you had bad or good
experiences with the uh the and I'm
speaking specifically of French French
speaking people from France not French
Canadians they're lovely they're they're
lovely and we've established that Swiss
French people are and I imagine that uh
you know Belgian males are as well uh
you know it's just the French French
it's just the French French OG is what
we're talking about it is born and bred
French yeah have you've had and they are
born in bread which is
but they're born in a little baguette
come sliding out with a cigarettes
a piece of bread smoking a cigarette
smoking a little baby green cheese you
know what I will say when we walked out
of that Lounge the um the women that
said goodbye to us said goodbye to our
kids and we're really sweet and told us
to have a nice day so it did end on a on
a nice course there are not the not
those particular women different women
different women yeah yeah of course that
woman was awful Rob's right she was a
terrible person she could have been you
know what she was speaking French she
could have been anything she just was an
all-around bad person yeah just bad
people are bad people no matter what
um but that's Nationwide International
that's International that is true
[ __ ] are everywhere like she could
be the greatest person and she's having
the worst day
that's the thing about stereotypes too
though that once once they're like
culturally established or in the
Zeitgeist then you are looking for those
you're looking for it yes that's why I
wanted to point out those very sweet
French women that said goodbye to her of
course of course now if you'd been
screaming about one in Cashew milk and
electrolytes to add to the water then
that would have been
Los Angeles of course of course well uh
sweetie thank you keep it together next
time you don't you don't need to um you
know fly around the world and
Fair have Justice be served everywhere
in front of our children alone with me
fine
come on you know the man you married
this is uh yeah it's hardwired Caitlyn
how are the Emmy parties did you have
fun it was they were so fun yes and I
will say I dragged Rob Kicking and
Screaming I did he was very lovely to go
with me and then we both had a really
fantastic evening it wasn't a fun did
you have fun I had a blast yeah it was
great we had so much fun did it was was
it were was anyone talking about me
I didn't hear anybody mention you at all
uh not Glenn specifically
um but a lot of people talk about the
show a lot of people people love the
show people
love the show can I also can I suggest
that there we have another member of the
of the family who is who is equally uh
as interested in Justice in in
situations Mary Elizabeth yeah she 100
she has a Justice uh gear which is a
good counterbalance to me because uh I
you know I have the Tom and Mary's gear
of just like it's nice ruffle any cute
piece keep the peace keep the peace
don't make the piece just keep the
existence
if there's any yeah whatever Pizza is
even if the piece is Injustice that's
fine
an existing piece but I don't like that
it's not a good quality you know it's uh
you don't like that in yourself yeah you
wish there was a little bit more Rob
Justice in you is what you're saying
yeah I think there's a balance like
everyone needs a little bit of it I
think Glenn and I are similar we're I I
can let a lot of things go and I'm also
like really compassionate like and I'm
always putting myself in somebody else's
shoes and I'm like it's fine she clearly
this or he clearly that but when someone
has zero regard for how their behavior
is affecting people around them I can't
take that and like if I get caught in
that middle of that I have to yep we
establish it that that was my number one
uh personality trait right yeah we did
we made some kind of a list of like
things and you guessed oh it was it was
when we were we were like it was the
dating game one where we were trying to
figure out who knew the most about the
other what made you the most angry
because people being inconsiderate yeah
yeah people not people not by the way
about how their actions affect us I feel
that stuff too but what happens is I get
I bury it down inside it gets tucked
inside and then look it could it can
come out on screen and in character form
sure and uh it's very useful tool but it
doesn't come out in life yeah I got it
on lockdown you'd like to write it for
my character though I and I write it in
your character the big emotional swings
we're not we're very you know that's not
a very that's why you like because you
really love writing my character like I
feel like that's my favorite one to do
yeah but uh yeah I like to stuff that
[ __ ] down inside deep and uh I feel it
I'm vibrating now thinking about it
well sweetie thank you for glorifying me
and corroborating uh everything thank
you for getting me cream I love you yeah
yeah I'm not sure
but that's the way I heard it and saw it
that's the way he chooses to hear it and
that's how it is love you all right we
love you Caitlin we love you I love you
guts bye I love you [ __ ] guts well
have we done it we did it I think ever I
think we I think the main goal here is
to always have people walk away from
listening to our podcast Having learned
something Rob Justice and Caitlin
context maybe that will be the name of
this episode or the cream of Justice
it always Rises to the top the sweet
cream of justice that you're always
talking about yeah
it rises up man
thank you